hi and welcome to episode number 29 of
the weekly Google klappa from podcast i
am francisco and i'm here with my
colleague mark Mandel hey Mark hey
France sku doing today break very happy
very excited about a lot of firebase and
firebase and firebase today yeah it's
going to be more fibrous and then some
more fibers yeah so actually the
question of the week and the cool thing
of the week are not related to firebase
yeah but which is not all not
everything's gonna be firebase but we're
gonna be talking with a bunch of people
from firebase again we're gonna talk
about all the new stuff they announced
it I oh and all that cool stuff so if
you had the opportunity to watch some of
the talks on the firebase track at
Google i/o there will be some of the
things that you might not but I'm sure
there's gonna be things that you did not
know that are new and old fresh in
firebase absolutely ah then at the end
we're going to be talking about the
quest of the week which is an
interesting one which is basically okay
so something's going wrong with my
application on Google cloud platform how
do I figure out what is going wrong hmm
so you're gonna be talking about
monitoring the bucking all that cool
stuff that you never want to do but you
have to yeah yeah so so yeah that's
gonna be fun that's gonna be at the end
of the episode but before that we're
gonna do the cool thing of the week yeah
so the cool thing of the week is
introducing on Google container engine
we have now gotten node pools yeah which
is really cool so what that really means
is you can now to heterogeneous clusters
so if you want to have different types
of machines within your cluster so
they're not all the same maybe you have
some with more memory some with more CPU
you're able to do that and then have
that all exist within the same cluster
and basically be able to turn around and
say like I want these these containers
to be running on these sort of like high
memoirs or I want these ones to be
running on a high cpu ones and so you
can have a little bit more flexibility
in terms of what sort of resources you
have available to you in your gk cluster
yeah and I think that since once you've
you had more than two not balls well
more more than one not both
actually you're able to tag those pools
attack those nodes accordingly and then
basically say I want this to be running
on some of those notes to have the tag
I'm em or whatever yeah yeah no they
actually get they get default Lee tag
just really nice with the new nodes and
like what they are when you create them
I actually really like this cute trick
here and then it's in the blog post
we're talking about but hey you can
create like if you want to do an upgrade
from one version of companies to another
the new node pools have the new version
so you can actually try out your stuff
on there oh you upgrade the rest of your
other nodes in your cluster and so you
can do some really clever things that
way too so you yeah it's actually yeah
it's pretty cool it's a really nice
little new feature that is very cool
actually think that it's a very good
match for Google Cloud spin again I
would keep on talking about it because
it's actually when you need to extract
something from frame you need a specific
naman of memory and so on but then when
you stitching stuff together you
actually meet more CPU other than
anything right so that actually you
could have different note yeah there's
people like really efficient with your
workload to you like only paying for
really the stuff stuff that you need I'm
very cool i consider doing that if i get
time ok so i think that we it's time to
go tap with our friends from firebase
yeah let's go talk about firebase so i'm
very happy to have a PS kings and dog
Stephenson from the firebase team here
with us today hi how are you doing I
don't ok pretty good how are you and
we're gonna be chatting a little bit
about all the new things that firebase
announced during google i/o but before
that why don't you tell us a little bit
about yourself why don't we start with
you yeah my name is Doug Stephenson I'm
a developer advocate on the firebase
team I've been doing Android for really
long time and I specifically work a lot
with the cloud test lab are actually now
it's called firebase test lab and also
crash reporting I mean if haskins I'm a
developer programs engineer on the
firebase team I've been working with or
for fire base for about three and a half
years now I joined when it was about 10
people
all before the database had security
rules and yeah I've been watching it
grow and now I focus mostly on the
real-time database but I do all sorts of
stuff cool so we've had an episode
previously about firebase but if people
didn't have a chance to catch it what's
like the high level what is firebase
what is what is this thing so far base
as a platform started as the database we
used to have this real-time database we
still have it too but we used to have
just this database and it was this
really cool way to interact with data
and build real-time applications but as
we progressed with that it started to
become clear that we were solving a
problem there but there was a lot of
other problems people had they had
trouble authenticating users they had
trouble finding a place to put
client-side applications HTML Javascript
stuff like that so it started becoming
this whole platform and today it's
expanded even more to be this platform
of things that most people do that we
can make easier things most people need
so it's just a suite of tools and
different different helpers to speed up
development and specifically like what
platforms does firebase work on so we
support a bunch of different platforms
we have iOS Android we have historically
huge presence on web lots and lots of
JavaScript development and you if I
remember for all of those are further
based specific indications for
frameworks we also have the c++ SDK that
is in development I believe it's beta
labeled now but I'm not quite sure but
that's also out there i'll save that
unity integration student here we do
have a unity integration which is a
wrapper on our native SDKs so all the
awesomeness of those come right into
unity cool and so that there's a little
bit of the history of firebase what
about the new firebase that we all now
we all heard about during google i/o
what are the new things that everybody
should know about well is it there's a
bunch of new things so like Abe said we
have real-time database which is still
the real-time database that you that you
know and love there are 15 total
components a button teen of which work
which are like wharf
our base and to which we're calling
integrations which are like standalone
products which just work well with
firebase so I'm gonna try to remember as
soon as I can I actually have the list
of the 15 components in front of me and
you don't see it so please go for a quiz
alright so let's see we don't get
anything wrong now yeah now see we have
real-time database we have storage we
have hosting authentication remote
config there's test lab for Android
crash reporting dynamic links I'm
breaking down here app indexing up index
invites in my I'm gonna rest rest stuff
I gotta help you a little bit there's
integrations are AdMob ok Edward Edwards
shirts and there's also notifications
and you guys message I'm the big one
yeah and also something that is the one
that you missed I think it's analytics
oh that's a really big one because that
supports a lot of the other components
very all all tightly very integrated
integrated with analytics yeah so could
you tell us a little bit more about
analytics itself yeah well it's what
does it do what it does analyzes yeah so
it's an all new analytics component that
is made for mobile devices so it's
Android and iOS it will collect and
report a lot of information about how
users are using your app automatically
so you don't have to write anything but
you can track your own events on top of
that so you have like a quota of 500
custom events that you can log and
parameter as yourself and once you've
started to collect all that information
you can then turn those events and user
properties into audiences actually
audiences you can you can define based
off of events that have happened for a
user's you can say everyone who's
launched my app and gotten to say level
three in a game you can create an
audience just for that you can also use
the audiences for notifications see what
else can you do you can also do funnel
analysis and you can export your data to
bigquery for
for querying um sort of ad hoc now I
believe this is free it is free and it's
unlimited it's kind of hard to think
about it like that you know so much data
going into the system say it one more
time because there's a number of people
who when they here free don't believe it
so is it free okay it's free as in f ree
lie up you know as in beer as a beer
yeah they're a yeah and unlimited
four-wheel unlimited so you can send as
much data into it as you want now that
is in crash reporting is like that to
crash pudding is also free and unlimited
but it's worth noting as a caveat you
can't just jam as much data as you can't
just spin up as much data as you
possibly can do there there is
reasonable usage patterns we have you
can reasonably handle you can't force
anything beyond that yeah wait there's
abuse vectors in place but for all
practical uses it's free online today
nice that is impressive yeah what sort
of use cases you think you're going to
see people using analytics for have you
seen anything already like I mean I mean
you can you can imagine that this is
Google's version of Google Analytics for
mobile and you can you know we have a
more than a decade of people doing crazy
things with google analytics and we
expect fully to see all of those times a
hundred with firebase analytics the
amount of flexibility we introduced with
these custom events and the ability to
do all these fun Ling's and
notifications and things like that it's
just it's huge and it's very open-ended
I haven't seen anything specifically
that sticks out because it's still very
early but I'm sure we're going to see
tons and tons of crazy things plus it's
free and that always brings up people
who build crazy stuff on things yeah one
of the things that people really want to
do is they want to identify who their
big spenders are so there's a concept of
lifetime value of a user and then you
can again use that to target them with
say you know notifications or put them
in a V testing with remote config based
on their prior behavior which is huge
for a lot of apps that actually segways
just into what I wanted to talk about do
you wanna talk a little about remote
config and what that is and how that
works yeah so remote config you can
basically think of it as like a
switchboard in the sky right so you can
you know it's kind of a goofy way of
thinking about it but trying to match
yeah so what you can do I mean there's a
few things you can do with it I think
the most popular thing is a/b testing so
you can have two different experiences
in your app and you want to pit them
against each other to see which one
makes more money or which one has a high
retention or has better you know
playthrough of for a game so you can run
that test you can define percentage of
six a 50-50 if people you know get one
experience or the other and then measure
the outcome in analytics the other thing
that people can do is say roll out a new
feature instantly so a prior problem
that app developers had is he had to
submit to the store and then the store
doesn't give you a guarantee about how
long that you know the new feature gets
out both Android and iOS have this
problem but with remote config what you
do is you code up your feature early
publish it ahead of time then when
you're confident that the app is
actually on the user's device is you can
use remote config to flip a switch and
then everyone gets the new experience of
the new feature instantly so you can
time that with like a television event
or a tweet or something like that make
sure that everyone gets the experience
at the time that you want them to have
it yeah and it's not just flipping
switches that you manually go in and set
like you can do that where you say I'm
going to change this value and then
users get some different experience but
you can do things where you say people
located in Australia are going to get a
different home page than people located
in the u.s. people running an older
version of Android might get a warning
saying you need to upgrade otherwise
we're not going to support this there's
a bunch of these different categories
and buckets that you can filter on so
just arbitrary percentage for a/b
testing that's there but we have a whole
bunch of different ways to send
different values to different people
yeah the other thing you can do is have
your strings in your app defined in
remote configs you can say in different
parts of the world change the experience
like for Android I'm an Android
developer so you can put that in
resources but you can't you know once
you've baked in those resources into the
app they're there forever right with
remote config then eat now you can make
those say whatever you want at the time
that you want in the part of the world
that you want I was going to say this
sounds particularly powerful you're
talking about sort of being able to
build your own audiences within side
analytics like say people have gone past
level 3 or something like that and then
being able to combine that with remote
configures well being able to say like
these particular audiences are going to
see this particular thing which is
different from people who say I've just
started or less experienced in the game
or whatever application you've got it it
sounds like really cool stuff so I have
a
so if I understand correctly the main
difference between using so if you want
to store some configuration that might
change over time you have the option
between storing it and real-time
database directly or store it in remote
config what is the big difference
between doing one or the other um I
think there is there's a handful of
differences the real-time database is
designed for small amounts of quickly
changing data let's always spend the
focus of the real-time database so if
you have huge strings that have you know
descriptions in different languages you
could put those in the real-time
database I would be fine but if you're
going and you're filtering them based on
language or something otherwise like
once they get to the device you might as
well do that in a system that serves
that up automatically ok it's it's
there's few things that you couldn't do
if you wanted to jam into the real-time
database and then like do this filtering
on your own but it makes more sense in
the interface is better for this type of
thing it also connects better to
analytics then just real-time database
was you'd have to be sending your own
events to say people are doing this and
that but remote conf it just ties
writing nice I think the other thing to
note is that real-time database is good
for storing model data whereas remote
config is better for just sort of like
regular key value pairs and also you
also get like a nice dashboard to make
the changes in that whereas with
database you have to go you know into
the database view or and drill down into
the item that you want to change then
change it and it doesn't it doesn't feel
is right you know and I think that's an
interesting discussion with the the new
firebase features we announced at i/o
some of them are targeted for more
technical people like the database or
authentication some are targeted at more
marketers or different business level
folks and I think remote config is
walking that line where if I give you
access to the database and your you know
my boss's boss and you know nothing
about our database structure there's a
really good chance you're going to break
something but if I give you access to
remote config and there's only if you've
let a few different ways you can set
things and you know can figure out into
then what not that's a marketing problem
like you guys can play with that and get
that right and I'll deal with all the
technical structured things that if you
break you're going to actually you know
take stuff down or what have you I see
so since you mentioned there
could you talk a little bit of
authentication because that's actually
probably made second favorite feature of
a firebase before the first one is
clearly the database but authentication
the fact that I don't have to manage
oath to my son that is amazing could you
tell us it'll be more about that yeah so
have you have you guys ever used like a
lot to set up like twitter login or
facebook login I've tried very hard not
to yeah I've done it again most people
have had about like nine times of trying
not to and then one time of like
succeeding but really hating themselves
for the fire based authentication is
just an attempt to make that the
experience it should be in that you as a
developer if you just want to sign in
with twitter you shouldn't have to be
running your own servers you shouldn't
have to deal with like these complicated
Oh auth handshakes that have like three
or four steps in them you should be able
to cite sign in with twitter and then
have the application you know pop out to
the Twitter app do whatever it has to do
to get that authentic authentic Asian
flow complete and get that back to your
app and that's what fire based
authentication does in most cases it's a
couple of lines to do with this
authentication in the web version it's
one line to pop up in a window we
dramatically simplify the flow of
integrating with third-party providers
specifically github facebook google and
twitter twitter yeah and with that
authentication we also offer if you
don't like those providers ability to
generate your own tokens and tie into
your existing authentication backends if
you have them and i do love the new
feature now you can do federated off so
that if people want to log in with
separate accounts for different both
providers you now provide the hook so
that you can just join those together
really nicely there's been a heavily
requested that's definitely on the sheet
of things that have been said so many
times we're like we're working on it
we're working on it yeah I don't think
people believe this anymore and then we
came out with it it's cool so there are
also several new features you have that
you've kind of absorbed into firebase
from externally the cloud messaging
comes to mind as well with test lab do
you want to talk about those two as well
and how they got pulled in and like
their differences now are they the same
like what will change there I think I
can probably speak about cloud messaging
and then Doug knows much more about test
than I do Cloud messaging firebase Cloud
messaging or Google Cloud messaging
serve the same purpose like you said we
kind of absorbed it in but we made it
more firebase you at the same time yeah
I want to know what that means yeah what
that means from our perspective is we
made it easier to use we made it
integrate better with the rest of our
suite of tools it's not just GCM with a
letter changed we went through when we
rethought a bunch of the api's and we
thought all right we have this existing
fire business to kill you're already
importing how much of this can we do for
you how can we simplify this how can we
make it tie into your analytics and
firebase notifications so we improved it
in that way it's much easier to get up
and running with then GCM ever was so
take a back ships for a sec what exactly
was Google Cloud messaging what like
what does it do for people in case
people haven't seen that before so cloud
messaging is a way of sending push
notifications to devices so some of
those pop up and make that was great
timing yeah so some of those you pop up
and you see might say hey you know you
should come beat level 3 of this game
some of them happen behind the scenes
and trigger to trigger things in your
app but it's basically just a way of
pushing notifications to devices okay so
yeah as you're saying like now it's a
lot easier to use and love that area
yeah exactly yeah it's never been a
horribly difficult thing to use but
wherever we could when we rolled
products and we improve the api's
improve the experience and integrated
them as well as we possibly could and
thats related to notifications to
there's now a different product yeah so
yeah this is this probably requires like
saying very explicitly there's been
confusion around firebase Cloud
messaging versus firebase notifications
this is fair it's a little confusing
which is which and how they relate but
you can think of firebase Cloud
messaging as the API the SDK that's on
your phone that you send on your clients
that lets you receive messages you can
also programmatically send messages
through FCM from your existing server if
you wanted to now FCM goes back to that
split I mean that sorry not FCM the
notification council goes back to that
split I was talking about between
firebase products for technical folks
and fire based products
more marketing business folks so if you
have audiences set up if you have your
analytics configured or different groups
that you want to filter and send
notifications to historically you'd have
to use a third-party tool you'd have to
go and rely on your analytics platform
to give you the ability to send
notifications to these people that's
what cloud of what firebase
notifications does for you it's a nice
interface to you I for non-technical
folks to go in and say I want to target
this group I want to send messages to
these people people speak these
languages get this notification or
whatever so messaging is more for the
technical programmatic people whereas
the notification stuffs probably more
for the less technical yeah exactly and
it yeah an important distinguishing
factor between them is firebase Cloud
messaging is more for like event-driven
messages so you have something that like
a notification that happens in response
to something else that happened in your
system whereas notifications is more
like you know user to you not user to
user but you know app manager to user
like I want to type a message in the
console and send it to my user so they
can see it so that's that case yeah yeah
and they both come back to fcm like
you're never going to import the f the
firebase notifications into your SDK
like once you put firebase Cloud
messaging in there you have the ability
to use notifications to send messages
down to devices thanks Allah and Tesla
yeah so it's formerly called fire based
test lab for Android because it only
supports Android devices right now yeah
but this is this is basically the same
cloud test lab product that's been moved
over into firebase so now you can do the
same things you could before so there's
a robo test which is like a fully
automated test that we have the software
agent that basically works your app for
you sort of discovers UI widgets and
buttons and pokes and prods and sort of
systematically crawls your app to find
all the features which is pretty cool
because you don't run a line of code to
do that you get that you get something
kind of for nothing which is great
because if you don't want to write
tesson I know I don't want to write test
us is not exactly like fun to write by
Friday I really enjoy writing test if he
also liked writing high school
so for people like you if you enjoy
writing tests you can do that you can
write Android instrumentation tests as
well and execute that against your abs
so you can upload both apks your app APK
and your instrumentation tests will run
those as well let's see what else can we
do with test lab there's guessing you
can run across various different devices
as well and side yeah stuff yeah so
that's what we call the device test
matrix so what you do is you select the
devices the actual models of devices
that you're interested in testing you
select the API levels the Android API
levels so you know not every device
supports every API level but we'll find
an intersecting you know combination
that will fit you can test in portrait
you can test in landscape and so you
know based on your selections will
create a series of tests that actually
satisfies your requirements that's cool
and do things run on real devices or is
it all emulated or how's that work yeah
so these are actually devices sitting in
Iraq in the cloud so you can think of it
like is it was like cloud hosted or
manage devices you don't ever have to
touch a device you don't have to have
tangled cables on your on your computer
you know back when I did testing at the
start up a long time ago it was like you
had the stack of device to consummate
let's do this one now let's try this one
let's try this one and only have one USB
port and I can't manage the whole thing
and so now you don't have to do that you
can run all your basically delegating
all of your tests into the cloud and
then we'll send you test results when
they're ready and they're running you
know in parallel so for as many devices
as you've selected we will try to you
know use them as fast as we possibly can
and did this platform change as it got
you know absorbed by firebase or is it
still fairly much the same or the
platform itself is mostly the same the
the big change is that we had a UI in
the cloud developer platform console now
that's been moved over into firebase so
now you you see test lab along with all
your other products you have that I
think the UI is better it's a little
easier to use but for the most part the
infrastructure is the same now there is
one new thing that goes along with this
it's not part of test lab proper it's
actually part of Android studio and this
is coming with Android studio 2.2 is
this a product called cassette and what
it lets you do is launch your app on a
device then you use it you you actually
type in push the buttons
the data for the test the way you want
to and then what it will do is record
everything you've done and create
espresso test for you so you don't
actually have to write out all of the
like on view click this button and that
thing and check that text like it's all
done in a UI which is super handy you
can grind through a lot of test cases
very quickly that way you say it was
called cassette cassette as in like what
I used to listen to music on when I was
a teenager yes well I used to save my
programs on yes I cool we're pretty much
running out of time but there was
something that I wanted to discuss to
was storage and how is it different to
Google Cloud storage if any difference
exists so it is different in the way
your interact with it firebase storage
is backed by Google Cloud storage when
you sign up for firebase you get a
firebase I mean a Google Cloud bucket
that you can interact with you can even
open it in the cloud console and if you
have existing apps that use existing
api's to interact with a Google Cloud
bucket you can interact with it well
from your firebase I mean your foot you
get your firebase bucket can be
interacted with in the same way the
benefit of using firebase storage /
cloud storage is that fired by storage
is designed to be used from clients
Google Cloud Storage never really had a
good solution the group I have a user I
want to upload an image i wanted i want
to upload directly to that bucket from
my web page from my app you'd have to
bounce it through your own server you'd
have to do checks on the file type and
the file size and things like that and
eventually you could get in the clouds
cloud storage bucket but it was it was
kind of wonky firebase storage
introduces two really cool concepts one
it's a client-side SDK for doing these
types of uploads so you can just say hey
upload this securely and safely directly
to my firebase storage and the
underlying Google Cloud Storage bucket
and the other is the security rules that
allow you to say okay this person can
only upload to this path inside my
bucket they can only over at their own
profile image it can only be I'm not I
don't know if this is out currently or
if we're working on this now but the
ability to restrict file sizes image
sizes things like that so you can say
profile and which can only be
this big or things like that so there's
a lot of benefits in that like I said
before these are things you could do
they're like authentication you could do
the OAuth flow or you could do this and
save yourself a bunch of time same with
this using just Google Cloud storage you
could have sent everything through your
own server gotten to the same point but
we just save you a ton of time now those
authentication rules those are just like
very similar to if not exactly the same
as firebase database real-time database
yeah so they're definitely similar
they're not the same syntax they they
are specifically used for storage like
there's very different requirements for
the store drills recency firebase
security rules but if you've ever
written database security rules you'll
feel very at home using this like very
descriptive nicely type thing to say oh
this location i'm logged in as this user
i can write here i can't it's it's very
very sane and you have all your rules in
one place so it's easy to look at in the
same way the same benefits you get from
the database security rules yeah i know
when i used it for what my presentation
i gave at i/o and it feels like
interacting with storage is almost very
similar to interacting with like the
real-time database you end up with the
same abstractions and it's super nice to
use and robably one of the nicest ways
i've ever used an interaction with the
Google Cloud storage so in the in the
same way that if something in the
database changes you can watch that
change in receive a notification can you
do the same thing for storage not really
ah what you can do is you can say i'm
going to upload this and then you'll
have a location in the real-time
database and when your when your upload
is complete you you know flip a switch
sale use the new version and everyone
can update so we don't have the ability
to do that type of updating today okay
because that's something yeah I could
have demos thinking about that there's
one cool thing you can do with a storage
so on the client SDK side you can do you
can kick off and upload and if it's
going to take a long time if you lose
connectivity will automatically resume
it so it's meant for large files as nice
user-generated content so if users
taking a bunch of photos you want to
upload them all you don't have to like
sit there and make them wait for it you
can like go into the background complete
in the background and be sure that you
know if they go into a tunnel lose
connectivity that's fine will restart
and it's also like fully secure so
everything's over secure connection
God's the firebase storage is definitely
the product that just feels like classic
firebase I think the most it's built
with things like that like that
resilience at the front of the real-time
database had was always a focus the
ability you can go through a tunnel and
your app keeps working storage we want
it to be the same way and it very much
is it goes back to the thing like you
could do that yourself but it would be a
pain yeah absolutely okay we're
definitely running out of time now but
is there anything that you want to
mention that has been mentioned or
something you want it like you want to
highlight a particular feature that you
think is really impressive or anything
oh so two lines I think the whole
platform is impressive and I'm not
saying this just because I spoke on this
topic at i/o but I think for advocate
I'm paid to say this no but it really is
very impressive when you look at all the
components and how they work really well
together I you know I look at it and I'm
like you know as an Android developer
going back in like 2009 like I had none
of this and now there's all the stuff
and so I'm kind of jealous that like if
I had if I had been what I had now I'd
be completely different things so I I'm
a little jealous of all the people were
starting up new projects you have this
platform to build on top of the you know
they're just going to have such great
suite of tools and you know I really
want to see what people build with it
yeah it's it's it's absolutely crazy
what we were able to launch and just
like how much I would like to be out
there using this like it's just such a
great suite of tools and you can see in
so many places it was just built by
people who were passionate and wanted to
help people and you know after I oh we
did this big launch and everyone was I
think expected to like take time off and
like go relax and like it was a week
after I oh and people are still putting
in these crazy long hours still working
on stuff not because things were
breaking like the launch went
fantastically but because they were
obsessed with building something awesome
and I think it shows in the product and
then they get absolutely does that
passion come stir and this is this is
just the beginning so it's I'm excited
for the future it's gonna be good nice I
think that that scent is a great way to
finish the interview absolutely that was
great yeah thank you so much oh thanks
for having us it was good thank you
thank you very much to Abe and Doug for
joining us today that was a super
interesting conversation about firebase
I'm particularly excited about all the
new features I think they're going to be
great yeah very very very excited
I saw a lot of people at Google i/o that
we're very surprised with the huge push
that firebase got all the new features
I'm very sad about using them yeah yeah
it's super nice to see the investment
that Google's putting into them yeah and
it's really i think is really gonna pay
off excellent so you wanted to have a
little chat about how do we debug stuff
that's a very broad statement what do
you what do you mean there it is a very
broad statement but basically the
question was something around okay so
something's wrong with my application no
and I'm not very sure what it is what
are my options like what do I do okay
and and basically the answer could be
something like well bride more unit
tests right but the problem is that what
is what if what is going wrong it's only
going wrong in production you know that
happens that happens and sadly happen
for you that it works on my machine it's
not it's not a thing really so so what I
wanted to like basically the answer I
wanted to give to this was there's a lot
of different things that you can do to
basically investigate what is the
problem in application on production and
most of them are actually under these
feature set that we call stack driver
yeah so stackdriver has a bunch of
things that you can do one of them the
first one is okay so if it's going if
something is going wrong there's two
different kinds of wrong yeah it's gonna
say like what what is wrong I mean right
so so one of the wrongs is you're
actually getting errors yep and in that
case you're gonna see that a stack stack
driver has a way of monitoring those
errors yep and putting them together
according to some template so you you
can actually get that hey you know like
during the last hour 500 occurrences of
these specific can ever happen you can
create alerts on that and get alerted
when those errors go higher than some
yes old so it's very useful yeah sec
driver error reporting is quite nice you
can also do stuff like oh this error
just happens and it doesn't get as I
just shut up yeah yeah but otherwise
like yeah this one's actually really
important and we need to get people out
of bed for this particular one yeah I
need that sort of error reporting and
then when that happens something that
you may can see there is a well
is going to go there and maybe you have
like a java application and i'm just
going to read the accept and the
exception stack yeah stack yeah just say
okay good i don't i don't know the
exception so yeah remember the name so
yeah you can check the exception stack
and understand what's going on but
that's sometimes not enough and in that
case there's this really cool thing it's
basically a debugger in production and
the buggerin production sounds like an
awful idea kiss putting breakfast and
your production is something that you
should never even consider doing it
please don't do that at home but but
what we have rather than rather break
points we have snapchat points yeah so
what you say is like hey I want to know
what are the values of all the call
stack and the local variables and all
the all that stuff that might be a
snapshot at this particular point in
time and you can even the add conditions
nice oh it was like when x equals then
give me all the values of the stuff and
then with that basically you you'll be
able to Canada back in production but
without the cost of actually stopping
any jobs in production which is a really
bad idea I'll actually put a little
thing on here as well it's super super
super alpha but there is a plugin for
google cloud platform IntelliJ and the
integrated debugging stuff they've got
for java application oh yeah Astra is
very very slick we're looking at
probably not worth trying just yet but
worth keeping an eye on it's super
interesting very cool and yeah on top of
that that you also get the other kind of
wrong which is things are just working
but just very slow and then in that case
you have the performance insights
analytic so you're gonna be able to see
what are the all the calls generated
from your request so imagine that you
get a request and rather than sending
one datastore read the read operation
you send 1,000 maybe there's something
wrong in there maybe you sent those 1000
one after the other so concurrency my
friend those things are going are
something that you can see very easily
with the detail performing insights and
the analytics that stackdriver provides
yeah so stackdriver trace is also really
cool and that it can give you alerts
when performing starts to degrade
it's not just a like a reactionary thing
for Mike users sending new stuff if you
start to see you can that you know that
performance is happening like you can
set up alerts and say like if if
performance on this website drops to 40
below a certain threshold or something
like that then you can be like hey you
know maybe you do need to get someone up
in the mill and I'd or at least in an
email or do something I'm super super
useful and there's actually a very good
talk that that if you're interested on
this topic you should definitely check
it out we're going to have to link on
the show notes as as usual and it's
called Diagnostics spend less time
diagnosing and more time developing yeah
i'll make one mention of one extra
product because i think it's worth
noting sure is the specter of a logging
like true super basic right but it is a
central place to send your logs like for
a lot of our platform as a service stuff
so App Engine etc that's just built in
like if I want to go see all my look
through my community apps or anything
like that I can just go right there but
I can also send it custom logs there's
API calls I can do it over the best I
can do it a whole bunch of different
ways and so you know like lug your
application so if you really want to see
what's going on inside your app just oh
good old classic text-based logs you
know sometimes it just does the trick
yeah something that just helps video
cool so I think that it's time to let us
know what are you gonna be doing but
where are you right now like let's
travel and to the future I mean today
it's so right now i will be in
minneapolis I'll be between two events
so tomorrow i will be at open source
north after that i will be at dev
objective and then ya later in the month
i'll be in new york for another event
which i still haven't got the details
for soon one day soon one day one day
that will come through and yourself
where will you be so right now if i've
been lucky enough not to crush my back
yet you don't do that now I'll try not
to I'll be somewhere right around
halfway from San Francisco to Los
Angeles maybe in pismo beach eating some
cinnamon rolls whoo very nice yeah
that's that's my hope really seven roles
in the middle of like a massive bike
ride exactly ok I will not feel guilty
for yeah you know what that's fair you
know what that's totally fair i totally
sounds totally reasonable yeah but if
while I'm away some of you miss my voice
I wanted to mention also i just released
a screencast of basically all the go
tooling that i usually today and it's
like 40 minutes which is pretty long but
i think it's gonna be fun there's 8-bit
music in the middle to make it more or a
really cute music i have to admit yeah
so I'll add a link to the shona too so
you can check it out and let me know
what you think yep and now we have
mentioned it in a while if oh yeah
people want to get in contact with us
let's see very well to remember all out
there alright so people want to reach us
on e-mail camp or no is your email
addresses in my email gcb podcast now
hello IDC podcaster come there we go
there you go so hello GV podcast com if
they want to be just I'm reddit that's /
now / r / geez podcast yeah they want to
reach us on Twitter GC podcast at
discipline focus there we go if they
went to reach us on google+ plus GC
podcast nailed it and we also have the
slack channel hash podcast in the gcp
community as you know and I feel like
I'm forgetting something I don't think
so no okay well that's pretty much
intimately I'm yes yeah the web page
Jessie podcaster come here you go yeah
that's got everything on it as well in
case you need any of those resources
great well thank you so much again this
week for joining me on these amazing
episode mark yes and thank you so much
for joining me good luck with your
biking next week thank you and talk to
you next week see you next week
you